Myanmar is the only country in the world
that eats tea leaves there they are
specialty served fermented with Crispy
garlic nuts and other vegetables the
dish is called La Peto and it is
absolutely one of a kind
[Music]
I can of course just eat the dish but as
this is great big story we're gonna go
on a little road trip to Myanmar to
learn how it's made
[Music]
foreign
the process for making latte takes two
to three months and has remained largely
untouched for thousands of years later
foreign
[Music]
and this unique flavor profile is used
in a wide range of Burmese dishes
[Music]
you know foreign
was used as a peace offering in Warren
kingdoms today it's considered a
national delicacy and is shared as a
sign of greeting and Hospitality for all
sorts of ceremonies
[Music]
lucky for me and any other Burmese
people living in New York City there is
a restaurant called Rangoon on 18th and
8th that serves traditional Burmese
cuisine
so I got the lapeto as well as two other
dishes that the staff recommended I try
there's the squash tempura and coconut
chicken noodle soup
this is the fermented tea leaf
it does have that fermented taste it's
pretty delicate though oh it's got like
a bit of an aftertaste actually that's
interesting
it's really nice
it's really fresh there's a bunch of
cabbage in here Tomatoes peanuts it kind
of just tastes like a really amazing
type of coleslaw it's got a little bit
of that fermentated taste in it a little
bit of heat and a lot of crunch it's
fabulous
so this one is a squash tempura
the battery's really really light
crunchy and the Squash is still a little
bit firm so it's not like a soft bite
this is very different very fabulous
and this dipping sauce has a lot of
Tamarind in it so it's kind of a sour
sweet Vibe going on
definitely order
we're going in for the soup
these noodles are thick
wow wow wow
what is in this broth it doesn't say
what's in the broth
kind of has like a peanut
the broth is really I'm gonna ask her
excuse me
what is in the broth so confirm that the
broth is coconut milk with chicken and
then a chickpea batter which makes it
brown this is
totally different totally fabulous
out of ten I'm leaving what I ordered in
the description so if you find yourself
at a Burmese restaurant you'll have a
little bit of inspiration on what to
order and I want to end with a question
in Myanmar the word for tea is lape but
most of the world calls tea either chai
or tea I'm curious what do you call tea
in your country